i'm mimi and i play ruby hi i'm shruti
and i play eric i'm acer i play photos
my name is dua i play cal hi my name is
jemima and i play hope and we are the
cast of sex education and we are with
buzzfeed ready to play
who's most likely to start laughing and
break character during a take chewy asap
what
i'm saying you because i i knew that
everyone was gonna i knew people were
gonna come for me we've just had a lot
of things together there's been a lot of
laughing but also i can i can admit i
think most probably me me and connor we
i just can look at him and he'll make me
laugh he doesn't have to do anything i
don't think i've been in enough scenes
with y'all like in like laughs laughing
scenes with y'all so i don't and i feel
like most of y'all are serious so i just
like literally just said mimi but i
don't
think last season there was an infamous
scene with me and me and basa in the
toilets as usual and there's a scene
where owen comes out of the toilet the
dead pig scene
we just couldn't do it i think it was
the last five minutes of the day we made
everyone wait behind about an hour
because we couldn't we couldn't get
through it
every
as soon as the camera went on it was a
wrap who is most likely to randomly
burst into song
[Laughter]
don't play don't get me started
don't get me started
he's in his head
it's true i do i do like like a good
song
i like singing i'm not really good at
singing leave me i just do the first
line and me
yeah no i take it off do the soprano
it's don't go breaking my heart
[Applause]
he used to sing it all the time and then
he got really sick of it so then i would
just randomly when we're gonna just
randomly start singing like why why
would you put it in my head and then all
day he'll keep saying and then and then
i'll be like humming under my breath for
the rest of the day
unbelievable i think i was going to say
amy too yeah amy amy
amy loves the song i think she only
talks in karaoke who's most likely to
get caught taking a selfie
yeah true
the libra and leo can take this one
we'll take this one for the team there's
no debate about this
who's most like their sex education
character
oh
i'm gonna say shooty because eric's
jokes and so are you yes and i love you
though that's the best i can come up
with thank you val take that one
jemima's a good person to ask because
you're a newbie it's true and duo
actually do actually who do you think
therapy i said amy the sort of
quirky you know person who sort of
likes to break the ice with a with a
sort of shocking sentence or something
i think it's easy for me to say that
because i never have a scene with her i
don't want to make anyone think they're
exactly like their character
because the quirkiness element but i
feel like you don't act like your
character at all i don't know i feel
like there's past photos that i've
resonated with but then parts that i
totally don't i think that's what i was
gonna say about amy amy's like i think
like more intelligent than her character
but i'm not trying to come for her
character yeah i think she's like more
like quick-witted as opposed to like her
character who's most likely to throw a
party after work nobody was throwing
parties during covet nobody did that
in a metaphorical party who would throw
a metaphorical party afterwards thank
you jemima i can't say i couldn't say
myself but it is
but i didn't say trish this is a culprit
it's i said you because you're you
always have everybody in your house you
just always have everyone there i'm i'm
the host
come over i'll provide food
i'll provide games and i'll provide
entertainment i do like to have people
over at night i like to unwind a bit you
know hope style who would you trust to
give you relationship advice to me
i don't know
because
i feel like we're all beyond the
given relationship advice i feel like
everybody's kind of messy in a way just
from the things i've heard here and
there i'm not talking from anybody i'm
kind of i remember i'm very happy and
i've been divorced already so i'm not a
person to ask but i did say you are
because you have this sort of sage-like
energy about you a sort of quiet wisdom
i would i would definitely ask you and
do it you're a scorpio as well i feel
like just wise right just smart you can
see inside people you're a good person
to receive advice from because you are
listening sure he will tell you exactly
exactly where he won't go around this
you'll be like no if something's not
right he will tell you and he will give
you on his honest opinion whichever you
who is
[Music]
and sometimes not everyone's playing the
game it's just me playing the game
that turns into a prank
i used to play a lot of pranks when i
was on set as a kid my favorite prank
was you'd get a bottle of water like
this
and then you'd poke a little hole in the
bottom
tiny little one just like a pin or
something and you'd walk around with
your finger over the hole yeah yeah
enjoy your drink oh yeah chat to someone
oh nice to see you
have a conversation then you take your
finger off the hole and you spray their
crotch with
water and they have no idea because it's
such a tiny little stream they don't
notice
and then you say goodbye you wander off
and then i had like five people at the
same time walk around and start looking
like they kissed themselves and it
was never ceased to give me
entertainment as a
13 year old boy
you